a story that may have been too dark for
disney controversial songs and in joke
easter eggs are what you're about to
learn in the next 13 minutes this is the
untold truth of the hunchback of notre
dame
in 1993 disney dream team gary trousdale
and kirk wise got a phone call from then
chairman of walt disney studios jeffrey
katzenberg who informed them they would
be directing an adaptation of victor
hugo's the hunchback of notre dame wise
and trousdale had a short but colorful
history with the company they
collaborated directly for the first time
on the rescuers down under from which
they were both fired but they reunited
for their directorial debut beauty and
the beast which proved to be an enormous
success it became the first animated
feature to be nominated for the academy
award for best picture and won oscars
for best original score and best
original song
wise and troussdale took a break from
directing after the grueling beauty
process but once katzenberg ordained
hunchback as their follow-up they became
determined to push the boundaries of
animation like never before
despite its reputation for delivering
happily ever afters disney frequently
draws on grim source material even so
victor hugo's 1831 novel the hunchback
of notre dame might be the least obvious
choice for cartoon adaptation they could
have possibly gone with hugo's tome is a
chronicle of human tragedy and it's one
that has had more faithful film
adaptations in the past
in the original story archdeacon frollo
and quasimodo both fall in love with
esmerelda as they do in the disney
version but in the original frollo
orders quasimodo to kidnap her this plan
is thwarted and quasimodo is arrested in
time esmerelda falls in love with
phoebus who is considerably less
charming than he is in disney's
adaptation frollo makes an attempt on
his life for which esmeralda is blamed
after esmerelda refuses his advances
frollo hands her over to the authorities
powerless quasimodo can only watch as
she is hanged filled with rage and grief
he hurls frollo to his death then
vanishes
years later his skeleton is found
clutching hers in a mass popper's grave
not exactly the most obvious choice for
disney and the changes they had to make
to turn it into a disney story would
prove controversial
where better to learn how to bring paris
to life on screen than paris itself
early into production the core hunchback
team set up a studio in the city of
lights to gather inspiration from both
the location and from the author himself
victor hugo lived just a few miles from
the studio about 165 years ago great
name by the way victor
hugo
they were even allowed unprecedented
access to notre dame kirk wise can
precisely recall the moment he
discovered the feeling he wanted the
movie to conjure
listening to this pipe organ in this
shadowy cathedral with light filtering
through the stained glass windows i
could feel it thudding in my chest
a similar moment inspired lyricist
steven schwartz to write out there with
composer alan menken's tune already in
place he sat in the bell tower early in
the morning before the public was
allowed in schwartz looked out over
paris and felt himself fully inhabit
quasimodo's world saying by the time we
left paris the song was written
the filmmakers went through hellfire to
cast the voice of quasimodo
one unexpected candidate was legendary
rocker meatloaf who auditioned for the
directors and composer alan menken he
was reportedly great but didn't fit
their idea of the role the most
memorable audition however came courtesy
of mandy potenkin best known for the
princess bride and homeland in what has
since been dubbed the potential incident
the actor arrived at his audition with
his own accompanist moreover this
accompanist had rearranged the audition
song these etiquette breaches didn't go
down well with menkin and lyricist
steven schwartz and when potentkin took
too long to get through his audition
tempers flared into open argument disney
ended up choosing tom hulse who was
actually nervous about taking the role
but when the directors heard his audio
for the scene in which quasimodo
releases a bird he's been nursing they
knew he was the guy they'd been looking
for the take was so heartfelt that it
not only got him the part it's the one
used in the movie
in the mid 90s demi moore was one of the
most in-demand movie stars in hollywood
having found fame as a member of the
so-called brat pack moore went on to
star in hits including ghost a few good
men and indecent proposal however she
wasn't jeffrey katzenberg's number one
choice for the role of esmeralda as
supervising animator and storyboarder
will finn told slash film the executive
wanted cher for the role even wise and
trousdale didn't think of approaching
moore but only because they didn't know
they could when they told katzenberg
they were thinking of quote a demi moore
type person for the role katzenberg
asked why they didn't just get more
trousdale admitted we didn't know we
were allowed to
reports about moore being demanding
turned out to be false as
detail-oriented disney fans will note
however esmerelda's singing voice was
provided by broadway star heidi
malenhauer
most disney movies contain an element of
comic relief often in the form of silly
sidekicks hunchback leans on this trope
too via esmeralda's goat jolly phoebus's
horse achilles and quasimodo's gargoyle
friends but introducing singing
gargoyles into a story this intense
didn't go down well with everybody the
gargoyle's personalities changed
dramatically throughout production
initially they were going to be voiced
by three of the era's most famous late
show hosts jay leno david letterman and
arsenio hall cindy lauper and sam
mcmurray were also nearly cast until roy
disney himself vetoed them ultimately
the gargoyles were played by charles
kimbrough mary wicks and jason alexander
with jane withers providing additional
dialogue after wix tragically passed
away some viewers felt that goofy
gargoyles don't fit the movie's intense
subject matter as it turns out some
people who worked on the movie agreed in
slash film's oral history of hunchback
then president of disney feature
animation peter schneider described
their presence as quote icky while
writer brenda chapman said i wasn't sure
if i liked how it ended up
though the entire movie pushes
boundaries there are two songs and
hunchback audiences find especially
shocking the first is hellfire in which
frollo struggles between bigoted piety
and overpowering lust for esmeralda the
original storyboards even depicted the
vision of esmeralda who dances in the
flames as naked that idea was shot down
but to everyone's surprise the studio
changed nothing else the demonic judges
the references to burning desire the use
of crucifixion imagery disney was
willing to back it all the other eyebrow
raising song is controversial for very
different reasons a guy like you
performed by quasimodo and the gargoyles
is a major tonal deviation from the rest
of the movie lyricist steven schwartz
was always unenthusiastic about it but
director kirk wise described the song as
a necessary interlude intended to keep
the audience from quote sitting in this
trough of despair for so long
if you're a connoisseur of the disney
renaissance then you've probably loved a
song by alan menken he composed the
scores for the little mermaid beauty and
the beast aladdin and pocahontas before
tackling hunchback he went on to write
the scores for hercules and tangled as
well menkin won various oscars for the
first four of those movies including
best original musical score for
pocahontas and best original song for
colors of the wind he shares both
trophies with hunchback lyricist steven
schwartz but out of all the music he's
done menken is most proud of the work he
did on hunchback
menkin told
film
it's the most ambitious score i've ever
written schwartz agreed that it's not
just menkin's best work but his as well
i think the music is just unbelievably
good i think as a lyricist i was working
at pretty much the top of my form i have
so many people telling me it's their
favorite disney film
when hunchback came out in 1996
animation had come a long way since walt
disney's day
but creating the crowds depicted in the
film's festival and mob sequences was
still a major undertaking
most of hunchback was animated the
old-fashioned way with carefully
hand-drawn pictures painstakingly
sequenced to create the appearance of
motion this is a lengthy enough process
with just one character let alone
hundreds so for those crowd scenes the
cgi department used then cutting edge
computer software to create several
animated character templates each was
then repurposed dozens of times with
different outfits hairstyles and
accessories
all of these models were then added into
the scene and choreographed to respond
to the main action the effect is a crowd
that looks like it's made of individuals
created in a fraction of the time a
hand-drawn version would have taken
many disney villains are so over the top
they're more fascinating or funny than
frightening but there's nothing funny
about frollo his evil is deeply and
recognizably human
he's up wait between lashes otherwise
the old sting will dull him to the new
the power he seeks isn't over an
abstract group he specifically wants to
control esmerelda and destroy her
community he is so clearly evil that
disney specifically changed his position
from archdeacon as it is in the novel to
judge so as not to insult the church the
scene in which frollo threatens
esmeralda inside the cathedral has a
distinctly disturbing tone at least if
you're an adult as the hunchback
filmmakers recall they thought they were
going to have a battle on their hands
trying to keep that especially sinister
moment in the movie
surprisingly they only had to make one
change
according to director kirk wise the
ratings board was most troubled by
frollo audibly sniffing esmerelda's hair
when the filmmakers agreed to lower the
volume of the sniff they were given
their g rating a very important thing
for a disney animated movie to have
although hunchback is a more serious
disney movie the animators working on it
still made room for in-jokes there's a
reason some of the most brilliant easter
eggs of the last decade are in disney
movies after all they're good at hiding
them hunchback has multiple connections
to the studio's 1991 mega hit beauty and
the beast
most obviously it reunited directors
kirk wise and gary trousdale and
composer alan menken and lyricist steven
schwartz in honor of their previous
project a special guest makes an
appearance early on bell can be seen
walking through the market square during
out there naturally she's reading as she
strolls
other disney cameos can be glimpsed in
that moment including the magic carpet
from aladdin and pumbaa from the lion
king maybe don't point that ladder
reference out to the kids though those
guys walking there they've got pumbaa on
a spit about to be roasted another
in-joke is hidden in plain sight though
only the most hardcore animation nerds
will notice it phoebus has the honor of
being the first modern disney hero to
have facial hair a tongue-in-cheek poke
at jeffrey katzenberg as kirk wise
recalled katzenberg was famously against
characters having facial hair so when he
left the studio during production on
hunchback the filmmakers jumped at the
opportunity to express their newfound
freedom by giving their leading man a
jaw-defining beard
hunchback remains one of disney's most
ambitious movies between the adventurous
animation searing score distinctly
morbid source material and attempted
blend of comedy and drama the film
pushes the limits of people's
expectations for an animated movie
although the studio had been supportive
of the film's dark tone during
production the disney marketing team
presented hunchback as a colorful
carnival entreating moviegoers to join
the party and merchandise tie-ins
reinforced this upbeat theme this bit of
misdirection backfired as it set
unrealistic expectations for confused
and unhappy viewers expecting an upbeat
romp and the film's box office chances
also took a hit when jason alexander
said that though he loved the film he
wouldn't want his young son to see it
some critics appreciated the mature
themes and style hunchback invokes but
ultimately few were satisfied those
expecting or wanting a pure disney
experience found it too dark while those
looking for a pure adaptation of hugo's
novel found it far too disneyfied with a
thematically jarring happy ending tacked
on still though not a smash hit
hunchback did okay at the box office and
some fans swear by it wise told slash
film
i've had so many people come up to me
and say this is my absolute favorite
movie that makes all the difference in
the world
the relatively lackluster box office
performance of hunchback didn't save it
from the indignity of a direct to video
sequel the hunchback of notre dame 2 the
secret of the bell was released in 2002.
surprisingly given critical backlash to
their silliness this sequel focuses
heavily on the gargoyles who help
quasimodo save one of notre dame's most
illustrious bells
the bell ringer also finally finds love
with circus performer madeline and a
successful 2014 stage musical has stoked
rumors that disney will be making a live
action hunchback remake in the style of
recent efforts like cinderella and mulan
will moviegoers soon be watching josh
gad swing from cathedral spires
considering the animated version of
hunchback was maybe disney's most
unlikely film ever there's no telling
what might happen next check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]